we love messing around with some
cutting-edge artificial intelligence
here at corridor in fact we've been
working with gpt3 which is currently in
a closed access state so sam thankfully
was able to get permission to use it and
today we're going to have that ai right
this entire video we're going to get the
script from sam's screen on our phones
and then as we do the action sam's going
to enter that back into ai so it's going
to be a back and forth loop as the ai
tells us what we do and then we feed
back to the ai what we did and it
continues our story we might be crossing
state lines in a couple hours i don't
know if i know what's gonna happen so
buckle up oh boy
so guys our setting is complete it's the
four of you on the famous green couch in
our studio we need the first prompt as
to what happens we need to make an
interesting video that gets 10 million
views what should we do
[Music]
peter replies
well how about we play a game matt
agrees that sounds like fun wren however
is skeptical i don't know if we have
time for a game we need to make a video
we can film in less than an hour nico
suggests we can do both we can film a
game and then make a video about why
people should play it matt jumps up
excitedly
that's a great idea we should play a
game that's based on a tv show what tv
show what about the walking dead that
would be cool we can play the game and
then talk about it
we just need to figure out the game what
do we need to do we need to roll some
dice matt jumps up and down excitedly i
love rolling dice
i don't know if this is a good idea i
don't really feel like playing a game
where we all die in the end
we wouldn't really die we would just
need to restart now we get to do an
action what are we going to do well do
we get some dice yeah you got to do
whatever you want so i'm typing niko
gets up and grabs an assortment of dice
from his dungeons and dragons collection
the first player was matt matt says i'm
going to roll for my survivor's name
rolls his die and gets a seven he looks
at his character sheet and decides on
bill my name's billy
[Music]
i rolled and i got a six i'm going to be
called sophia
oh i rolled and i got a three
i'm going to be called carl
i roll for my survivor name she gets a
an 11.
i'm going to be called laurie
brennan turned into a girl all of a
sudden
[Music]
now it's time for the starting equipment
and their mysterious persona nico gets a
baseball bat
my mysterious persona is t-dog
hey i get a wolf whistle guys matt gets
a wolf whistle
[Music]
my mysterious persona is lori
rem gets a pickaxe
and my mysterious persona is andrea
peter gets a handcuff peter gets a
handgun
next it was time for the players to make
their first move they could do anything
in the game that they wanted as long as
they rolled the corresponding number
apparently now we're playing a dice
space the walking dead game i'm gonna
roll the dice we'll see what i get we're
gonna feed it to the ai it's gonna tell
me my next move this is pretty cohesive
now
everything we're doing like makes total
sense
nego rolled a 10 which means that you
can look for supplies if you find them
you can take an item to use in the game
[Music]
nico decided to look for supplies and
found a can of beans
oh yeah t-doc's not going hungry tonight
matt's turn okay all right i hope i get
a good one
matt also rolled a 10 which means that
you can look for supplies
matt decides to look for supplies as
well and find some batteries
[Music]
wren's turn i'm rolling
12. i rolled a 12.
you can move in any direction as long as
you roll the number rolled on your dice
rind decides to move north but rolls a
5.
go north yeah go north red there you go
a little more north
there you are that's north
all right here we go
i got a 13. peter rolls a 13 a very
lucky number which means that peter
decides to move forward two spaces and
now he's in the bathroom see you later
so i guess
this feels like a lot more than two
spaces
[Music]
right now the ai's been dictating this
game and of its own accord it now said
it was now a time for the players to
encounter an obstacle peter's turn
you find yourself in a bathroom
there's a zombie in there
oh
oh he's in trouble
go find peter go find peter right now
peter decides to fight the zombie
but he misses completely
wren runs after peter and attacks the
zombie with his axe
but he misses completely
nico's turn
nico attacks the zombie with his
baseball bat he misses too
[Music]
you guys suck you're so bad at this
matt's turn hold on guys i got this one
you decide to go in the bathroom and
kill the zombie
zombie bursts into flames and turns into
a pile of ashes everybody cheers
the blood of my eggs these cokes make
guys
continuing here ren's turn
you decide to look for supplies
i pick up a pile of ashes and add it to
my supplies it still thinks i'm a female
these are the zombie ashes that i have
now cupped into my hand
ad
break hello sam i have a new task for
you today oh yeah uh what can i do
computer today's sponsor is expressvpn
and i'd like you to tell your audience
about it
what do you want me to say jake usually
does these segments i can compile a
script from the talking points if you'd
like me to yeah that would be really
helpful because i don't like know what
i'm supposed to say
okay generating a script now
script complete okay here's how
expressvpn works for me certain shows
and movies are only available in certain
countries depending on the deals they
have with distributors and expressvpn
lets you change your country of origin
online so let's say you like german
netflix you can just quickly say hey i'm
a digital german with expressvpn if
that's your thing i'm more into canadian
netflix i open netflix and start playing
a movie presto i can now watch any movie
i want to remember when they were mad
when the office was taken off united
states netflix turns out with expressvpn
you can watch canadian netflix where
they have the office still it's that
simple canadian netflix is the best
netflix i can also watch canadian
netflix on a number of devices this is
crucial to me it's because i travel a
lot for work and always have my iphone
or my ipad with me so i can watch
canadian netflix no matter where i go i
really love the fact how expressvpn lets
me stream canadian netflix in hd the
video quality is great i use a vpn to
secure my internet connection you see
when i use expressvpn i can connect to
the vpn server in canada and the
canadian server acts as an intermediary
between me and canadian netflix
that means
that means when i stream canadian
netflix through a canadian server
netflix
they think you're a canadian and they
treat you much better so if you want to
watch canadian netflix or any other
netflix head over to expressvpn.com
that's expressvpn.com
corridor crew and sign up for three free
months all right
time to watch some canadian netflix
it was now time for the final encounter
before them the big boss appeared it was
massive it was scary it was a huge
walker in a police uniform
the authorities
[Music]
the group was scared they needed to roll
a 20 on two dice only then would they
win
the 5-0 it's massive it's a huge pile of
crush
wow said peter unsure if they would be
able to do it why don't we put the dice
on the number 20 then reverse the
footage to make it look like we didn't
cheat that's a great idea that would be
awesome we could make it look like we
really rolled the 20. they put the dice
on the ground with the number 20 facing
up
right
they blow on the dice to make them move
then they rewind the footage
[Music]
that looks pretty good
we made it like we rolled a d20
i don't say anything
even though they cheated they rolled 20s
which meant that they decide to fight
the walker
[Music]
congratulations you have won the game
the end everyone laughs and high-fives
that was fun
i agree it was really fun
good job everyone i think it's time to
make the video now
wait it's not done
[Music]
do it do it baby we're just getting
started
yeah let's start filming
we can film it now everyone else agrees
as they sit back on the green couch
welcome to the corridor crew today we
are going to tell you about a video game
we played it's called the walking dead
and it's awesome yeah we all played it
and we all loved it i was in second
place and i beat everyone else and i had
the most wins
and i had the least amount of wins
it was fun and we all had fun playing it
that's why we're going to recommend you
play it
[Laughter]
wow that was insane that's really trippy
it gave us like an intro and an outro
basically yeah that's incredible we came
back into the review of the game like we
said we were at the beginning of this
project wow it knew
that when this game was over that means
the video was done and i i didn't i did
not touch that at all sam can you give
me an ai uh version of like requests for
like likes and subs
you ready you ready to act this out just
tweet it out
red and peter nico and matt also done
the famous green couch from the quarter
crew studio nikki wanted all the viewers
to like and subscribe so i said hey
everyone please like and subscribe and
then he farted really loud everyone was
mad at him for being so rude while this
was happening another quarter crew
member was filming the whole thing on
his phone when they were done he
uploaded it to youtube
are we actually going to upload this
really this is a real video are you sure
it's
fine
[Music]
hit it again
[Music]
you guys suck you're so bad at this